so hi guys I'm Tomatoes dommage
we are going to talk about recognizing
products from descriptions basically
from names of the offers on our side and
you think most of the talks you were
healed here today would be some kind of
success stories in our case we chosen
like two examples from our daily work
because we felt that there are a great
example to compare two different
approaches the baby they keep
traditional machine daring shallow
machine learning and deep learning so
like you shouldn't expect to see and
mind-blowing results but we will rather
focus on online differences between
those two approaches if you come from
Poland then you probably know Allegro we
are the largest e-commerce site in the
region and basically on our site you can
find different sellers who sell their
stuff and it's like almost everything
starting from I don't know some small
items made with fashion ending up on I
don't know computers many different
things and one of the problems we have
is that since there are many different
sellers the descriptions that they
provide power for the products vary in
quality very much sometimes the
descriptions are like very precise
sometimes they're really random and we
would like to either identify the
products so first of all because we
would like to know what is being sold on
our platform
second of all we would like to make good
recommendations sense like good for
example market good marketing emails so
we have like let's separate those for
this
and we you can identify products using
many different approaches you can try
using for example regular expressions
this is a British text that you see on
the bottom is a regular expression to it
identify this name of a kind of car
tires as you can expect this wouldn't
work for many many many different
categories of products this is very
limited but in this case it actually
worked pretty well so we tried machine
learning yeah so so we we had this
problem and we didn't want to approach
it from from a point of view of a
classification of identifying particular
product but rather seek to find a
pattern that that can be identified as a
new product this is because the product
bases are quite limited and vary in
quality and so on and and second of all
because there's new products coming
coming up all the time so so we want to
be able to look at the offer name and
just see the pattern that will give us
some idea on the product name so so we
started this approach from well matching
the the offer names with some product
databases and this way we we got a view
of of a split offer name looking word by
word we were able to to create a target
variable actually by assigning a 0 or 1
to each word so this is something that
that we want to predict taking some
other name we want to to assign these
values to two particular words and then
getting the the product name in in this
way so yeah you can already see that
well sorry for this being in Polish but
it's actually a screenshot from from the
website but you can see
the the product name here is is already
quite noisy okay so what we did first
was to try to use a simple approach so
this is a problem that for a human eye
is quite well-defined and it's sometimes
quite problematic to see some some
patterns and and well you are able to
develop some intuition on what is
important in in this this task what can
be some distinctive features for
particular words so so what we did was
to engineer some some basic features
like of course offer category because in
each category there's some certain
specifics of offer names even though
they are quite heterogeneous then we we
got to certain specific features of each
word so what land is it a number or a
character word because we're splitting
characters for from numbers what was the
position in name this is this is
actually here in this example already
quite visible this is usually the case
that for example the name is earlier in
the offer name it's not always the case
but it's we will see it's actually quite
quite a good prediction method for this
so for example matching this with some
some brand dictionaries also lets us get
some information so so these are some
features of particular words and what we
wanted to to see to get some context on
each word was to to get the same
attributes of of the neighboring words
so we got four for each of these words
we got the characteristics of the
previous word the next word and so on so
there's there's no vectorization we are
only interested in features of these
we're not interested in in the words
themselves actually so this was the
initial input and this actually worked
for us pretty well because the the first
attempt on doing it this way was to try
and clean up product database quite well
structured product database that is well
a bit too too difficult to manage by by
some heuristics but there are some
identifiable patterns that are not too
complicated so when we use this we had a
balanced data set because roughly half
of the words were actually at this waste
that we are looking for and we had just
like 37k observationally at at word
level and yeah we've run some some
random forest XG boost and some simpler
models and without much effort we we got
over 97% accuracy in test precision you
can see it all worked very well so so in
in a short time without many or much
computation expense we were able to to
get a tool that worked really well for
this kind of data yeah and actually here
you
we could see already that in this case
for example the position of what was was
the most important thing for production
in case of offer names this is this is
much more complicated we because we will
be dealing with with much more
heterogeneous data so so actually this
kind of approach was something we try to
apply to offer names now and the main
algorithms that we used were under
forests and in order to to make the
computation simpler we used extremely
randomized trees which
which are simpler mainly because they
they don't optimize the the cutting by
the at the split they just randomized it
but we found out the performance DD
accuracy and all the metrics are really
similar but the fitting time was was
like three times shorter and actually
and another thing this was all trained
locally on no 70 million observations I
think and and this is something we could
do pretty quickly in case of memory
problems a laptop this kind of an
sampling works really well because we
were able to loop it and well it didn't
make any requirements on special
architecture we see later on that this
this is something that we we have to
consider in case of deep learning of
course so the the results that we got
here was 76% of accuracy by by word this
is this is actually not really
impressive we'll see that we can use
very very simple tricks to get to this
point precision recall were were
actually quite good but what was
important was that even though we got to
24 percent of perfect matches so an
offer was was perfectly matched product
each where it was classified properly
when we set the treasure of the the
tolerance threshold to two one or two
words we we can get the coverage to 50
percent for one one error offer name or
in case of two words almost free first
were were correct so assuming that
actually there is not there's actually
no one correct solution this is
something that that was not so bad I had
to say
yeah so now let's see where Ned's next
step was to to apply to this data
another approach of deep learning and
Rita McCool say something about it
alright so another possibility steep
learning
everybody talks know about declaring so
we'll also talk about deep learning this
is not yet the planning this is
something much simpler actually mmm we
would like to use the planning because
we would like to work with world text of
the descriptions but the problem is that
every machine learning algorithm wants
from us numbers so we need to provide
data in the form of numbers one thing we
could do is we could simply match map
each word to some kind of number one hot
encoded and end up with like hundreds of
thousands of one hot and column vectors
basically the problem is that this would
also read to like hundreds of thousands
of whites in our network and model will
be huge
so thing one thing we could do use we
can use feature hashing it's a very
simple trick we use a hashing function
this is some kind of function basically
Maps the words text any word has input
and maps it to some number from a fixed
range so the problem that we potentially
have is that we can have different words
map to same number and this is your
value problem in computer science but
actually it's not that much of a problem
for machine learning it appears that it
works pretty well
if we do like this sometimes it's work
even better if then using like only one
hodkin an opening on rewards and what
happens is that by introducing this kind
of noise we prevent
from overfitting this was also the case
in our example because using one using
future hashing instead of some kind of
tokenizing helped us to reduce the
number of what the vocabulary like by
1/2 or something like this and the same
time a little bit improving the
performance of the model so it worked
like the most basic thing you do when
using the planning and when working with
language but also any other categorical
variables is we use embeddings the the
basic idea of embeddings is that instead
of using very long vectors with zeros
and ones in 100 codings we use shorter
vectors of floating-point numbers so it
doesn't sound very clever but actually
it has pretty nice properties because by
mapping those factors to something
shorter first of all what we see is that
the vector will become meaningful so the
similar words are represented by similar
vectors and also we usually see quite
nice relations between stores of vectors
so so you probably heard about those
examples where you can for example that
some of like King and male is the
something similar to some of Queen and
female new public health of the result
of the grant was another tax so Bendix
is like the lowest building block for
the network and we tried several
different architectures for this problem
we tried one dimensional conversion and
therefore works with right record and ok
let's start
with one dimensional convolutional
neural networks the basic idea is that
we have some kind of sliding window that
goes through the sentence let's say that
the sliding windows is of size stood and
it basically looks at pairs of words and
each of the sliding windows six for some
kind of pair of words that it finds
important so with many sliding windows
like this we basically look for big
grams of was another aqueduct
architecture that we tried this was this
architecture that was using recurrent
neural networks so the idea because be
behind repair neural networks is that
the network looks at some particular
world but also looks at the context it
looks at it selectively can remember or
forget what what what what it was
looking before so it doesn't look only
odd on the words or on Perse but also
you can look at all their history we
also tried
[Music]
quasi required no networks so this is
basically something in between recurrent
neural networks and convolutional neural
networks and actually all the
architectures work really similar there
wasn't much difference so I'm focusing
around right now underground hooks in
this case we used by directional eros TM
layers so this is the kind of player
that looks at the history so that
previous was but it look also looks at
the future words so it goes in both
directions at the same time skip
connections so some kind of information
flows into lsdm something that goes out
and then we sum the input with the
output this is pretty popular
architecture for convolutional neural
networks but also for recurrent ones
it was trained on on single GPU with
atom optimizer or some kind of learning
rate scheduling era stopping and several
different tricks now if you would like
to have some kind of intuition what the
work what the network was doing and
there is this picture and what it shows
it shows what would happen if you would
changed some world from the cover name
to another word choosing at random this
is of course repeated many times and
averaged so what we see is that if we
replace one of the first two words to
something completely random
those first towards if you are not if
you don't and polish are male shoes then
it still thinks that the probability
that there are part of the product name
is zero that's why it's black and it
still thinks that all the other words
are almost surely product name now if
you change Reebok the name of the brand
it was pre pre pre processed so we don't
see the repeating character but is the
brand then it start swinging that's okay
this random word is rather not a part of
product name now if you change something
from the middle of the of the sentence
then the network becomes it it gets lost
basically it starts thinking that okay
maybe something in the end of the
sentence is a product name so basically
some of those strange numbers and the
jogger maybe this dusty product name and
and while changing like last part of the
sentence to something random it leads to
makes this network think that the
beginning of the name is is a product
name so what we see is that the network
doesn't look at the single words it
looks at the context and it looks at
some groups groups of of words for sure
and sometimes it makes a global decision
like in the third line from the bottom
sometimes it makes very local decisions
like with like word a brand name so it's
pretty flexible actually now if we look
at the results as I said in the
beginning nothing impressive the
accuracy is 88% precision and recall 80%
for 28% of titles we had perfect match
so this is far from impressive but I
think that those numbers are not really
that that relevant for the problem
because if we would like look at what it
predicts then the predictions are really
really reasonable in most of the cases
that's not a metric of course but you
can look for example how often does it
predict very short names and doesn't it
predicts names that are like four words
at least towards so it seems that it's
pretty reasonable also it rather doesn't
happen that it predicts it doesn't
predict anything it happens with a
similar frequency as in real data and it
has many many properties that are very
similar to the distribution of the
original data from the from the training
set or or the test set so this tells us
that
the distributions are pretty similar
nonetheless that there are small
differences that make the basic like
global statistics drop also was
interesting it that is that if we use
this algorithm and we predict the names
of the products more data set then we
see on average three distinct predict
names per product on in our data set the
one that we used for training it we had
something like fifty of our third
product so we reduced fifty different
descriptions to only three different
names so that's actually pretty good and
what's even better is that the top of
those three names was predicted for like
on average 64 percent of office so in
most cases we get only the single name
per product and some noise a detail so
that's not bad actually
okay so so we'll try to make some some
comparison between these two methods
based on what we learned when when
approaching this task so let's let's see
about it so there's there's actually
plenty examples when neural networks are
being over performed live by some easier
methods so for example there's this
paper by China come true
Matt love and Monte from from this year
when they make a comparison between
polynomial regression and neural
networks and I'm actually several
examples then they demonstrate some even
advantage of regression over neural
networks this is this is of course when
we're dealing mostly with with some
tabular data so so actually
in this simple simple cases so for
example we have this plains database
here as the airline data data set as an
example so there are some some cases
when when we don't have to resort to
such computationally expensive methods
we we can actually get meaningful
results from from some some less complex
solutions and this was actually the case
for us with with the first step so the
the product database cleaning where we
got really good results without without
without much effort and much computation
actually so to make comparison between
these approaches we have the main matrix
here so the the first one is is just a
dummy classifier global mean so assuming
zeros the second one which actually
performed surprisingly well I think was
position white means which in effect got
us to selecting first for words from
from the other name and yeah we've got
almost I think 80 percent of accuracy
well we can see that the other matrix
not on par with with the rest of what
we've done but but still it's it was
quite surprising to see that we can see
that all the random forest doesn't
doesn't really achieve even even
satisfying accuracy it tends to to
perform similarly to neural networks in
terms of precision and recall of course
when we're looking at results we we've
seen that the neural networks may made
simply more sense yeah and I think one
one thing that we probably
the information is that the problem I
think that the reason that we had such
problem with which with getting better
metrics is that our data is very noisy
what I mean is that first of all that
descriptions of the product by the
sellers are really noisy they convention
I don't know shipping time is faster
from me or you can get something for
free if you buy this or this is a very
great offer or some really different
stuff but that's not the biggest problem
because also the database of product
names that we have is also noisy it's
also made by humans so our labels are
already nicely because of it so we have
nice the input and nice the output so I
think that's the biggest problem because
we are often when we train those models
like both machine learning style machine
learning like deep learning we are we
were very far often overfitting to this
kind of noise in this data set and I
think this this really reduced those
metrics pretty yes to finish with a
comparison of these two approaches so
this this kind of share of machine
learning was was relatively fast to
train so actually we found out that in
case of of the trees we we got to pretty
fast we we got to a level when we got no
additional accuracy growth in adding
more trees so it really didn't require
much computation the results can be can
be good in in cases when we have this
intuition of what the TaylorMade
features could be and
when when we applied this this kind of
domain knowledge so the our first use
case proved prove that this this can be
done in achieving high accuracy of
course less computation out-of-the-box
less hyper parameters or almost none in
case of this kind of treason sampling
impact of model choice and hyper
parameters on results can be better
understood the case for interpretation
also can be made we saw from previous
presentation that there's advances in in
terms of deep learning model
interpretation and what we've seen here
that it can be good for for structure
than tabular data and on the other hand
in in terms of of deep learning we don't
have to apply any any domain knowledge
in well not as much so we don't have to
engineer features as much we can we can
provide almost raw data and and get
interesting results the family of models
is flexible the performance is tends to
be good on larger that databases will we
actually didn't stumble upon much
problems in in terms of fitting it on
large databases because the libraries
are prepared for that so yeah of course
it has to get much data yeah I don't
know if I skip something I think that's
the most important points I think that
they like it's like very important to
pointing out that the biggest problem we
had was overfitting to those random
patterns in our data that were totally
meaningless and most time of the tuning
of the model was about regularizing it
so that it doesn't know if it yeah and
also if something was
clear enough then we like provided some
kind of links and resources that you can
check out that are very clear and I
think worth recommending to to get a
better understanding of something that
wasn't clear enough Thanks well question
for lunch and this one okay thank you
for the speech you have amazing prepared
I have a question regarding word and by
word abiding you have trained have you
trained your word embedding from scratch
using only Allegro database or maybe you
used some external databases like
Wikipedia or something like this we
trained it from scratch I know that
there are other teams that also use deep
learning in our grow that you use pre
trained embeddings
but my personal opinion is that our data
set is too specific and this kind of non
grammatical names non grammatical titles
that sometimes like nothing to do with
real Polish language and there are very
short they use numbers some strange
symbols in the names so I don't think
that it would be reasonable to use
pre-trained and bending sound on some
other data set and also we have like
huge data set on our own so we can train
on our ladies